[Music]
is beerus a good character
I think reef Oakland the past with the
issues I think Dragon Ball super has had
from the pacing to the lack of tension
in certain scenes and even the way a lot
of characters have been written and one
character that comes up time and time
again in these various scenarios and
conversations has been beerus the
destroyer so I went to Twitter and asked
my followers what they thought of the
character asking them if they thought
the character had served Dragon Ball
super well the verdict and responses
were more split than I thought they'd be
after 5,600 votes cast and almost 200
comments discussing the topic the final
tally was 71% in favor of beerus and 29%
disliking his inclusion however the most
surprising part for me was in the
comments section which painted a much
more negative picture for our purple
egyptian cat monster so let's dive in
and try to understand the pros and cons
- one of the most iconic characters
introduced to modern age anime he's one
of the most important and powerful
characters in the 7th universe and in
the entire Dragon Balls story this is
the problem character beerus the god of
destruction
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I don't really think it'll come as
a surprise to any of you watching this
that I'm a massive fan of the series I
followed it since I was eight years old
which means I've been watching dragon
ball for close to 20 years now and in
that time I've seen the main series end
and continued through without the
original author directing the story and
whatever your feelings are about Dragon
Ball GT whether you love it hate it or
aren't indifferent to it it's sort of
impossible to deny that it turned a lot
of people away from what was the single
most successful manga ever created for
the time and so when the announcement
came that Akira Toriyama was taking the
Dragon Ball story back into his control
continuing it forward where we last left
off I and many others were very excited
but anxious not because we didn't love
Dragon Ball or the idea of it coming
back but for a lot of us we didn't know
if it would feel right there's something
about the original series that feels
sort of distinct and it's clear that
whatever that dragon ball Ness is people
find it difficult to replicate
faithfully without turning a large
portion of the fanbase sour there is
something about Akira Toriyama's
characters from how they are designed to
how they act and conduct themselves that
oozes personality and even hints
oftentimes at hidden complexity from its
long list of villains and heroes Akira
Toriyama created a world of his own and
brought to life by filling it with tons
of colorful interesting and endearing
characters pushing the main message of
Dragon Ball which is to push your own
limits pass what others think is
possible despite great adversity it's
not easy to create a character and I
think especially when it comes to Dragon
Ball Z it's easy to introduce or create
a character that takes themselves way
too seriously and I think that's really
evident if you look at most of the
o'seas created by the fanbase and so
maybe it was a good thing that Dragon
Ball ended the way it did it left the
series open-ended with the journey
continuing indefinitely as Goku went on
fighting and training the future
successor as the Earth's protector
Dragon Ball Z had already created a
massive problem for the series in
focusing on giant climactic battles that
continuously increased the scale and
consequences of each subsequent
iteration by the end of the series many
of us became desensitized to the stakes
and the consequences because they had
become too impossibly large to fully
appreciate in a lot of ways but in 2012
your
Toriyama decided to continue Dragon
Balls story and had a remedy for that
very problem from the very first scene I
was introduced to this brand-new
character I immediately fell in love
with him noticing not only what it meant
for the series moving forward but also
appreciating how perfectly he fit into
the tone of it
he's devastatingly powerful but also
very endearing and light-hearted a lot
of the time and that's incredibly
important especially for Dragon Ball if
he was nothing but powerful that would
be boring very boring acting as the
film's antagonist not villain
beerus offered exactly what the classic
Dragon Ball formula needed overwhelming
competition for Goku that's another
aspect of what for me didn't work well
within the Majin Buu saga itself because
the Dragon Ball story is largely about
Goku and because of this how he
interacts with the story is incredibly
important his character is designed such
that it's most interesting when
discovering new things and when he's on
the back foot in a fight much like he
was when he was against Frieza in their
first outing watching Goku try to
overcome intense adversity and
opposition creates moments that we will
always remember and I think it's safe to
say that beerus pushed Goku into these
winter dire circumstances that created
moments precisely like that moment with
Frieza on now
for me it's abundantly clear that beerus
has a defined unique character and
offers a massive expansion to the dragon
ball or opening up massive new worlds
and opportunities for us to talk about
and enjoy but that's not to say that he
doesn't have his problems massive
problems and these problems started to
surface when the second modern Dragon
Ball film was released what I think is
most interesting about this particular
character is that these tributes which I
praised in the beginning half of this
video are precisely the root causes for
many of the issues people seem to have
with him now and these gripes came up
time after time after time in the
comments section of my poll on Twitter
you see almost every aspect of beerus
that acted as a positive for him in
battle of gods and the show thereafter
from resurrection F and to an even
greater degree in Dragon Ball super as
I've said before one of Dragon Balls
biggest problems was Goku and the main
casts ever increasing power level
raising the stakes to ridiculous absurd
levels and while beerus his presence
does give goku a chance to be an
underdog in a fight he also provides a
massive downside that Dragon Ball and
Dragon Ball Z never once had to contend
with a loss of tension Dragon Ball Z is
one of those series that provided
countless nail-biting moments where we
were left on the edge of our collective
seats wondering if Goku is Vegeta if
tension on our room ever was going to
pull through that tension that suspense
is what made Dragon Ball so incredibly
compelling it's why when I pick up a
Dragon Ball manga and open a random page
I get sucked in so easily it always did
a terrific job of creating tension and
one way of breaking down tension sucking
the atmosphere out of a scene is like
this lots fearless that's not polite
freezer you forgot to say Lord now I can
understand that many fans of the beerus
character will offer the argument that
beerus really isn't on anyone's side
he tries to be neutral and really
wouldn't care too much it frees a
defeated Goku there and then but that's
sort of the problem that mentality
surrounding what should be the biggest
fight to date in the series makes
everything feel less important it makes
us think well what's the big deal about
watching the second best fight that can
happen and when your film and subsequent
television series doesn't pay off beerus
at all it makes me wonder what does he
offer this scene what value is he adding
and the answer is none well that's not
entirely true either but it did ruin the
flow of the film and the enjoyment of
the battle for a lot of people including
myself the fight scene takes up a large
chunk of the film and a massive turning
point narrative Lee within this movie
was how Frieza would react to Vegeta
being yet another obstacle to overcome
despite finishing Goku through clever
tactics imagine how suspenseful freezes
defeat of Goku would have been had
Vegeta being the only other person left
to settle things and imagine if we
didn't know if he even stood a chance
it's difficult now to look back at what
could have been but this for me is a
massive part of what made this movie
significantly worse than battle of gods
however with that said it's not like
beerus didn't to offer anything to the
film his presence in that scene offered
some levity through humor that only
someone like him with a far superior
power level could enjoy during climactic
scenes like this one however even with
the humor and light-hearted endearing
banter he expressed in the prior film in
this one it really starts to become a
tiring routine in resurrection F at
least for me
it became extremely obvious that the
writers felt obligated to include beerus
but didn't have the first idea of what
to do with him they needed Wiese as his
involvement was crucial for the film to
reach its conclusion but beerus was just
sort of there i mean if you really think
about it what changes if you remove
beerus from this equation not much and
unfortunately his involvement wasn't
without a massive drawback to the
overall atmosphere of the film and
scenes and it only got worse from here
a strength that beerus offered to battle
of gods was that he showed yet again
that there will always be someone
stronger than goku that concept works
fantastically well in a movie format
that lasts around two hours it's sort of
a natural extension of what Dragonball
and go whose philosophy has been
throughout the series but take that
concept and now stretched across a 131
episode long series and you get a
character that sucks the drama and
stakes out of every fight the main cast
is in and proves to be less and less
funny with the same style of jokes
popping up again again again now that's
not to say that I don't think beerus has
any funny moments at all in Dragon Ball
super again he has had some moments
where I got legitimately amused by him
but he honestly provides more misses
than hits when it comes to the comedy
section his presence largely serves only
to turn the spectacle of a massive
dragon ball fight into a couple of kids
having a scuffle while he the dad
watches from the park bench
he has great moments that exist within
the series itself and I will acknowledge
that wholeheartedly he's had some
brighter moments that have shown him
more interesting side to him on occasion
but again it's been more misses than
hits when you take into account the
entire series so in that lies and in
that vein I understand that people have
a distaste and are fed up with the
character despite having terrific
upsides early on and one of my favorite
designs for a character in the entire
show it's obvious that the talent behind
toys writing staff as well as a Keira
Toriyama really have nothing for him
while we wait for his inevitable rematch
against Goku and nothing demonstrates
that more clearly than the Broly film
they had nothing for this character they
needed Wiis involved and because these
two are sort of attached at the hip
beerus once again like in resurrection F
is forced into being involved
however unlike resurrection F they seem
to have learned from their past mistake
and sidelined the character almost
immediately after he showed his face
look my main issue with beerus isn't
necessarily his character i actually
really enjoy it
his personality is playful and
compliments Goku's in a fascinating way
that even Dragon Ball super has
demonstrated I love his design I love
the general theme of what he has going
on but strangely it's how he fits and
complements many aspects of modern
Dragonball that I really don't like tons
of folks complained over the lack of
tension in Dragon Ball super early on
and the two arcs that happen to have the
most tension were the ones that traveled
to the future without beerus involved
and the universe survival arc which
again beerus couldn't be involved with I
personally think we're at a point right
now where the next move for beerus is to
be lesser than Goku or Vegeta witnessing
how he reacts to this sudden shift in
status quo could be interesting and
offer a lot in the way of development
for him if that's the direction they so
choose but until then in my opinion
beerus is still something of a problem
character
thanks for watching
[Music]